hello freak [ __ ] yeah you know that
what that guy's going through right now
the renter he's like in the groove and
the other guys where I go to pony [ __ ]
that he do and just shits on his rant
when she got hit a farm when one guy
just starts talking over the other guy
yeah they lift on their toes and get
louder and louder yeah because there's a
chick there and they're trying to score
that's the worst you ever have a friend
that would insult you and girls were
wrong oh yeah whoo I had a friend
[ __ ] knock me down once with we runs
well there was a nice there was a lake
near my house growing up and we used to
skate there it was [ __ ] unbelievable
I grew up in Tarrytown New York and we
had this reservoir that actually feeds
New York City it's like the main
reservoir for the water drinking water
in New York City and so it would freeze
in the winter and then they had this
Shack this big [ __ ] wooden shack
twice the size of this room and it had
benches and it had a little snack bar
hot chocolate and hot dogs online then
you go outside and there's like a wooden
wooden steps going down into the lake
with telephone poles they put in this a
big [ __ ] Lake telephone poles around
half the circumference of the lake with
spotlights and radio speakers and they
would crank [ __ ] pop music and you'd
go out there until 11 o'clock at night
we'd hide six-packs in the snow on the
banks of the lake we go after we're in
seventh and eighth grade drinking a
couple beers hitting on chicks and so
I'm out there one night and then during
the day we play hockey all [ __ ] day
they had metal nets they would put out
and they would use a plow to plow the
snow to make rinks out of the [ __ ]
snow on the ice whoa
it was insane and this is before global
warming that [ __ ] froze by Christmas and
we were skating in March every [ __ ]
year March well early March how do you
know when to stop well it's three feet
sick how do you know when it's not three
days they tell you that a town tests it
Wow there it's all there's a big there's
another shack on top of the hill where
they have spotters there's guys that are
rink you know guys skating with jackets
that are the rink guys and so so anyway
I'm there and I'm talking this chick
from the next town over Celine was her
name I remember this
deep voice brown eyes real [ __ ]
Italian girl that was my type a little
plump Italian and I'm talking to her and
all of a sudden I get [ __ ] knocked
down this kid Chris Spencer had skated
towards me and just check me just
[ __ ] and I fell down hit my head
couldn't get out for a little bit and I
was like what the fan my friends were
laughing it's like what the [ __ ] was
that Chris was like trying to break into
our little circle of friends and he was
this big dude and he lifted weights and
that was his way of like getting into
the group was to [ __ ] knock me down I
was talking to Sal in and I tried to
fight him later after when I had my my
sneakers on and thankfully somebody
broke it up he would have [ __ ] kill
me but um
cut to Oh insulin like me at the time
cut - what was it Halloween the
following year we're running around and
somebody sprayed shaving cream in my
eyes and so I chased him down and it was
somebody dressed as a bum knock him down
sitting on top of them punched him in
the face people start grabbing me
screaming dude it's a girl
so I [ __ ] run away turns out it was a
little bin Oh No and guess what guess
who had a bigger crush on me now her
yeah after you beat her ass tell me
about her [ __ ] childhood whoa really
yep so what happened to Jim to apologize
and know I was in the next town so I
didn't really I just ducked out of
seeing her how many times you hit her I
think a few times she's a girl tryna why
did she spray you in the faces she know
it was you who know we used to run
around with we would take shaving cream
and we put aerosol tops on a shaving on
a Barbasol can spray each other you know
and you came home we were covered you
were a snowman when you came home right
we'd have eggs and we'd slap each other
in the forehead with an egg and we'd run
around there's always one a silhouette
in there and then you have to go home
early cuz he sprayed [ __ ] air on your
head
oh so she she sprayed shaving cream my
eyes I couldn't see that well Wow and I
knocked her around Wow I fought like
abuse charge I got punched me on the bus
once really yeah I was like weird thing
man when I was 14 I got on the bus for
uh for the 13 year olds like a junior
high school bus and there was this guy
who actually became a buddy of mine
later he was young back then Bugsy
Malone and got the [ __ ] hey I was a tiny
little dude at the time he was I think
he's two years younger than me and
anyway some girl was mad at me for
something I remember what happened but
she started throwing punches at me and
I'm like what the [ __ ] and I block her
punches and then I looked down and the
dude was like right behind her and he
said something to someone else said
something them and he looked at me goes
yeah and afraid of you either I was like
alright okay
just what the [ __ ] ever man he's like
can I fight this girl before I fight you
mouthy well sis I just [ __ ] up I was
new to the town and I don't know what
happened when she was mad at me for but
I remember blocking punches by some
girls trying to beat my ass like [ __ ]
are you doing
and this little dude mad at me too but
Mugsy Malloy was he wearing a little
newsie cap well in the 1940s I'm super
lucky I never hit that girl back cuz it
turned out she wound up dating my friend
Mark who's the captain of the wrestling
team like afterwards yeah like after
this and he would have killed me he was
an animal and he was a couple years old
us I got was 14 he was 17 he was a
senior and he was like one of the best
wrestlers in the state he was an animal
he smoked cigarettes in between
wrestling practice he'd be in wrestling
practice and that girl that tried to
beat my ass she would she would open up
the door he would go outside and like
wintertime out and he would like take a
couple of drags of a cigarette really
yeah yeah yo Molly was wrestling like at
a really high level he was smoking
cigarette yeah he was like a thug so
athlete interesting like a legitimate
bad [ __ ] like an animal he was
an animal wrestler made me realize like
real early on like wrestling practice
made me realize like how hard some
people workout I had no idea how hard
some people workout yeah because I had
taken like karate classes before and I
had played baseball but I never did
anything like wrestling yeah in my first
days of wrestling class I remember
thinking what the [ __ ] a unit has worked
this hard
we have to go upstairs with the carry
someone on our back and climb up stadium
stairs and what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
yeah like what we were doing what we're
doing endless drills were firemen
carrying each other back and forth
across the [ __ ] gym racing each other
and constant live drills with wrestling
I would leave there I could barely walk
or so tired I didn't I didn't do any
homework I was wrestling yeah then I
just want up doing no homework ever
that's true with wrestling you really
[ __ ] up your grades you come home
annihilate annihilate it you're hungry
yet you guys want to sleep and then did
you have to try to lose weight from her
yes I did but I wanted up stop and doing
it because my friend Steven was
wrestling to 128 pounds he was a better
wrestler than me so I went up to 134
which is basically like what I weighed
when I was 14 so or 15 whatever I was so
it's pretty easy I said I didn't have to
cut any weight at all but then I cut
wait for Taekwondo
when I stopped wrestling and I started
fighting in Taekwondo I cut a lot of
weight up until I was 17 and then when I
was 17 I was still trying to make 140
pounds but I'd be walking around like
150 something I would just starve myself
and dehydrate myself was terrible really
[ __ ] with my performance yeah and then
I stopped doing and I went up to 154 and
when I went up to 154 I became way
better that was when I got better yeah I
was holding myself back by the dieting
and I think that that's a big factor
with wrestlers but one thing with
wrestlers is that their mental toughness
because of that weight cutting it's
almost worth it because the mental it's
super bad for your health to cut a lot
of weight but those guys who can do it
and still compete they have the ability
to push through discomfort and just have
a drive to win very few sports can match
yes very few sports where will the
athlete compete in a state of like on
call
for as much as wrestlers mm-hmm they're
just dieting yeah starving themselves
dehydrating themselves and still going
out there like [ __ ] savages mm-hmm so
it's a just a different kind of sport
man difficult part but anyway that girl
basically beat my ass I mean she didn't
really beat my ass but part of me was
younger than you to think she was my age
now she was on the bus - she was like
taking the bus back but I was thinking I
better not watch this girl oh my God
look glug didn't I get smacked by a gay
kid nice kraid oh [ __ ] you got pimp
slapped I got pinched this this black
kid Keith he was really effeminate so we
used to tease him I'm not proud of it
but like at that age
you just kind of did it was like you
know I'm embarrassed by it like we you
know you said whatever you know [ __ ]
your wrist and say [ __ ] and he turned
around and [ __ ] smacked me across the
face and I and he stunned me I was like
holy [ __ ] and I don't know what to do
because he was he was part of a family
it was there was projects in Tarrytown
and there were cousins and there were
families that had a lot of cousins and
his his cousins were some badass
[ __ ] the davis's own know and
so this isn't to say I necessarily would
have hit him after that for a number of
reasons one of which I was not that
tough I was pretty tough with girls
on Halloween but but I think I was just
so shocked did you know that you
deserved it did you have a feeling I
deserve I got hit a lot of the kick and
I deserved it most the time I got
punched in the face of Times Square when
I was about 14 hurt I walked past some
guy who was like some [ __ ] a homeless
drug addict who was like coughing up a
loogie and so I started coughing really
hard - making fun of him came back and
punched me right in the face whoa
you don't want you beat up by a junkie
no not in the days of AIDS that's right
it was could have been an AZ punch no I
used to get smacked around I was I was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I was such a wiseass
because I was the smallest kid so that
was how I fit in I was the funny guy who
made fun everybody
I would pick fights because then my
friends would fight the fight I was that
guy
well certain things that kids like when
they're growing up and one of the big
ones is things happening we like action
yeah like something happened if it's
he's gonna go [ __ ] with that guy you're
gonna kick his ass like because we're
bored yeah we had no [ __ ] intern and
we have no songs we stood on a street
corner for five hours that was Saturday
night my friend Kenny would just start
fights with people he would just go find
someone like a bus stop and just start
beating that no [ __ ] really come on
we're fighting it was crazy Wow yeah
watched him fight one want some good ass
kicked he did it once with this guy and
the guy knew how to fight guy was
beating his ass good he's just crazy
what's the kid's name Kenny who was his
deal it's just nuts
who's older than us he's like 1 1 or 2
years older than big guy nope nope not
particularly big just [ __ ] tough as
nails
he had a boxing tattoo in his arm like I
think he had a Tasmanian devil with
boxing gloves on they didn't really box
yeah just one of those things like never
made it to an actual gym like maybe a
couple of times yeah but we just start
fights it wasn't really that good at it
yeah it was it was just crazy he just he
was crazy he wanted to fight and he
realized that with his limited mentality
and view of the world that the most fun
that he had was when he was fighting as
I well that means we fight and so he
just would want to fight all the time
like one time my dog got hit by a car it
was really sad I was on a busy street
and my dog I opened the door and she got
super excited to go for a walk and she I
did never on a leash and she ran out
into the street I just didn't anticipate
her running she was usually pretty good
about it and she ran out got nailed by a
car she's oh so sad she died right in
front of me I carried her back to the
house and she she [ __ ] herself like
that's why I knew something I didn't I
still didn't know something was wrong
but looking back I would have known just
[ __ ] all over the kitchen and I was like
I can't believe she [ __ ] herself like
what like what she never shits in the
house and then she just slowly slipped
away just lie down and just stop
breathing man just bled blood from the
inside internal bleeding she hit my
Volkswagen bug no kind of dog she was a
mix she was boxer and I think she had
some
german shepherd in her - mmm sweet dog
sad [ __ ] man who's sad [ __ ] who's a real
bummer man was a real bummer but anyway
I told Kenny I never had it I mean I had
dogs die we had a dog that we adopted it
had distemper when one up having to put
it to sleep start going crazy it was a
adult dog not adult but it was over a
year old and I was a Doberman and it
just started barking at us and snarling
its its teeth and just started losing
its mind and we got it calmed down
enough we'd get a leash on it brought it
to a vet and that's a distemper we had
to put it down
so I'd had that happen before but I
never never seen a dog die in front of
me sad [ __ ] yeah
so I tell Kenny he's like what fighting
that's it come on out we'll fight and
Rogin your [ __ ] fight no excuses
tonight and we drove around and you like
wanted me to pick fights with people my
dealer I'm not [ __ ] fighting okay
that's the way he would deal with his
emotions mm-hmm yeah pretty sure
sadness fight anger fight looking for
excitement fight it's an it's also
there's a thing about young guys where
young guys always want to be the crazy
one like all mics the [ __ ] craziest
mics [ __ ] crazy Michael and give a
[ __ ] and it becomes like a social status
among young especially we were talking
about this before the podcast everybody
our age was like a last key kid
everybody our age had a mom and a dad
that worked and they open the [ __ ]
door in the morning and you were off to
the races yeah you went school after
school they weren't home for hours right
you did a bunch of [ __ ] by yourself and
most of the time were around other
[ __ ] savages our age so it's the
abstract influence of the parents on the
children that is really like giving you
your experience for who you are as a
young person yeah you're you're
experiencing how these people taught
their kids and what the result was
because you're around the kids all the
time not around your de perak now they
say that you're raised by your peers
after about the age of 12 you're
basically your parents are out yeah
you're raised by your peers yeah you're
constantly with your friends in school
you're consoling with your friends and
any activities you have you're looking
for their validation instead of your
parents validate exactly and with my
friends it was always who's this
is [ __ ] Oh Mike's a sick [ __ ] you know
Steve's the sickest [ __ ] he doesn't give
a [ __ ] he's crazy
and there was like a value in that
because everybody was scared that was
really at the bottom line of it we're
all young men and we're on our way to
becoming adults and no one knows what
the [ __ ] they're going to do we have a
few friends who graduated high school
and they're losers now and like [ __ ]
that might be me like that was the big
cloud that was always hanging over
everybody's head what are you doing
after high school what are you doing
after high school and it was like this
impending date of doom that was coming
up so everybody was scared all the time
yeah and everybody wanted to be they
wanted to be a man everybody wanted to
prove themselves they wanted to be
something special no one felt special
you know everybody felt like [ __ ]
loser you know we're all like waiting
waiting to become an adult so you get a
job like all these are the people you
knew that were around you or escape or
figure out a way to escape yeah then
there's always the Community College
like people global you know I'll
probably end up when you hear I'll
probably end up at the Community College
that's going to be one semester and out
I did that I went to Mass Bay Mass Bay
Community College I did it after a whole
year I took a whole year off and I just
I only went back to school because I
didn't want people thinking I was a
loser so I did like maybe one semester
of math bad don't even think I finished
the semester and then I left and went to
UMass UMass Boston had this like adult
education program we didn't have to have
a GED or a not g8d SAT cuz I never took
my SATs when I graduated from high
school I'm like I am never going to
school again like [ __ ] this but I got so
tired of feeling like a [ __ ] loser
like when I tell people hey I would
always say I was taking a year off
cooking a year off mm-hmm but it really
I just had no direction all I was doing
was like doing martial arts and
competing and I just was so terrified of
what the [ __ ] the future laid and so I
went to UMass for like three years but
not like three full years like there was
still a lot of credits to be acquired if
I was gonna graduate and I just was
wasting my time I was barely paying
attention I wasn't doing
I was completely half-assing whatever
project we had and I was realizing like
what am i why am I wasting my time yeah
and then I got some letter saying that I
couldn't come back with the grades that
I had unless I came up with some very
compelling reason so
wanted me to make an argument for why
they should include me back in the class
and I wrote out in hand Britain because
back then no one had a [ __ ]
typewriter this total [ __ ] letter
this ridiculous
like a persuasive [ __ ] e letter
about how important education is to me
and I'm poor
how important it means and and then I
realized like the amount of effort that
I put writing this [ __ ] letter to
keep these people from kicking me out of
their school which I wasn't paying
attention to far exceeds any effort that
I ever put on any project ever in class
yeah and then I realize okay whatever
I'm gonna do with my life it's not going
to involve doing this yeah it's not
going to involve someone else dictating
my schedule like whatever reason you're
like clearly I can write yeah clearly I
could really I think maybe comment yeah
well I had a conversation with a science
teacher this science teacher and it was
the same kind of thing I I mocked him in
class not necessarily mocked him but I
brought up something that was contrary
to what he was teaching he was talking
about a Lake Erie being a dead Lake and
I said listen man they had a documentary
on PBS last night about Lake Erie making
a resurgence and these scientists have
figured out these new ways to minimize
water pollution and all this [ __ ] like
other kids looking at me like what the
[ __ ] and he got pissed at me he got
really pissed at me and he said you're
undermining my class and this night I go
hey man
you're teaching old [ __ ] yeah how you
teach all this is on TV man this is on
TV like yesterday yeah and I had a
conversation with him afterwards and
because I had to talk to him in order to
get back in the class he kicked me out
of the class and he said two things he
said one he said first of all I don't
know whether or not that was the case
whether or not it's true and if I allow
you to just interrupt my class and chime
in something like that and it's not true
I haven't fact checked it you're telling
the whole class and I don't know if
you're right or you're wrong or you're
making things up but you're interrupting
my class that's the point if you have
something to tell me about it
maybe you can tell me about it after the
class and then I can go and look it up
and then maybe I can correct the class
it was but to in interrupting a class
you showed yourself to be more
articulate and more
intelligent that you ever showed ever in
the entire semester so you're totally
half-assing everything you do you're
writing everything in paper you turn in
every test you do every time I call upon
you for a question totally have to have
asked that but when you wanted to
correct me on something also you knew
all the words you knew how to form the
sentence correctly you got to say with
the right impact like just you just your
focuses off and it was like god damn I
dudes on the money mm-hmm and I realize
I'm like yeah so I'm not stupid
right I just can't I can't listen I
can't do it their way I got to do it my
way right I could I just didn't I grew
up not having any direction yeah so
someone doesn't tell you what to do all
your life essentially you just out free
I would go fishing I'd hang out my
friends in the [ __ ] woods we just go
find [ __ ] to do and then all sudden
you're in school and they're telling you
everything you have to do all day like
I'm not ready for that I'm not not only
that like you're sitting it I'm [ __ ]
shocked when my kid tells me about it I
go what was your schedule today
well you know at 8:15 we sat down for 15
minutes for homeroom then at 8:30 I go
to my first class which is an hour and
15 minutes then we get five minutes off
and we go to another class it's two
hours pick up these long [ __ ] classes
and it goes like that till three o'clock
and you can like thinking like 25
minutes for lunch and they're sitting be
boys
with [ __ ] chemicals racing through
their bodies and girls in the next desk
with [ __ ] short shorts and cleavage
and little brown titty sticking up you
know when the breeze hits them and they
get a little bit of goosebumps on the
inside of the cleavage and that cross
Jesus is just wedged right in between
those two brands for the Italian horn
you telling you know and it's got
glitter on it remember she wore the
Italian yeah hombre
how about charm bracelets charm
bracelets yeah the [ __ ] flips lobster
and then those times were painted them
move the toes very important the girl
doesn't take care of her toes now can't
trust her with her [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah
she lays I hate to do this on equal pay
day
[Applause]
[Music]